il est 16 heures les derniers clients du
service de midi terminent leur repas
bien content d'avoir eu le temps d'en
profiter
on a réellement le plaisir de l'assiette
mais après je dirais que c'est le lieu
le service qui n'agirait que des
personnels ont nettement moins de temps
pour le faire
à peine ses clients partis toute
l'équipe du restaurant s'activent dont
deux heures à peine les prochains
clients vont arriver
l'organisation a donc dû être revu
totalement faut pouvoir être présent
depuis le service de midi jusqu'au
service du soir en continu et donc j'ai
c'est pareil j'ai sein de l'équipe en
deux en deux ans deux équipes tout
simplement
donc on est un quasiment continue là
maintenant depuis 11h le matin jusqu'à
21h le soir 17h tout le monde est de
retour en cuisine au moins une heure
plus tôt que d'habitude mais pour des
menus adaptés aux contraintes actuelles
nous proposons un menu unique en quatre
services à 59 euros qui permet à nos
équipes de le servir dans le temps qui
nous est accordée et sans bousculer
absolument pas le client
en voilà on lui garantissant cette cette
expérience on sait à d'après aussi et on
ne peut pas servir des menus à 8 dudit
service ça on n'en est pas du 17h50 les
clients du soir commencent à arriver
peut-être pas vraiment affamés mais prêt
en profiter c'est quoi qu'il arrive un
plaisir de venir dîner donc que soit 16h
18h 20h 22h je pense que la féerie et et
le
l' envie de venir elle est présente j'ai
vécu pas mal en angleterre où manger à
17 heures la bêtise a de toute façon
besoin d'eux dans le changement d'heure
donc la nuit tombe déjà donc on commence
enfin
résultat des taux de fréquentation très
bon mais au prix d'une réactivité d'un
effort considérable de tous à vous les
responsables de l'établissement